-Dorinda, we have
so much to talk about.
-So much to talk about.
-You know I'm a fan of yours.
-I hear your wife is, as well.
-Nancy. The Fallon family
loves Dorinda.
-I love Nancy.
-Oh, we love you so much.
-Are you shocked or surprised
ever when a celebrity is like,
"I'm a big fan of yours"?
Because I know there are
some famous ones out there.
Sarah Paulson.
-Yes, love her.
-Lady Gaga loves you.
-Yes.
-Rihanna.
-She wants to come
to the Berkshires.
-I have this. She wants
to come to the Berkshires.
You posted this.
And then look, down here,
badgalriri says,
"I wanna come over."
-Riri --
She can bring the baby now.
-She can bring the baby.
-It's so easy.
It's such a baby-friendly place.
-It is?
Yeah, I want to come by.
So Rihanna
hasn't been there yet?
-She hasn't been there yet.
-Rihanna, open invitation.
-But I've got to tell you
a funny story.
So, when I called my parents,
who everyone has seen on TV,
and they're older now.
-Yeah.
-They live in the Berkshires.
I called up and I said,
"Hey, Mom. Guess what."
"Hey, John,
your daughter's on the phone!"
So, of course, it's 20 minutes.
They make it on the phone.
They pick up.
"Yeah, what's going on?
Everything okay?
"Yeah, everything's -- I'm going
to be on 'The Tonight Show.'"
"John, your daughter's
gonna be on 'Johnny Carson'!"
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
And I just couldn't
break it to them.
-[As Carson] "I'm very excited
that you're here tonight.
It's unbelievable."
-It just cracked me up.
-[Normal voice] They're like,
"What is going on right now?!"
-Oh, they're gonna be so asleep.
[ Laughter ]
-You've had some of
the most iconic lines
in "Housewives" history.
I want to show
a couple of these.
Because these were memes
that went around online.
-Uh-oh.
-No.
I just loved you
right after this.
You said, "I decorated.
I cooked. I made it nice."
[ Laughter ]
"I made it nice."
-And that's a sentiment
that all women feel,
like, in the world, you know?
And I'm going to tell you --
Because these girls
were acting terribly
and not appreciating
anything I was doing.
-Yeah, exactly.
-And I was fed up.
-Yeah, and you gotta tell them
what's up!
-I cooked, I cleaned,
I made it nice!
-"I made it nice!" Come on.
-We've all felt like that.
-This one made me laugh.
"Martinis are like breasts.
Two are great.
Three are too many."
-We've seen it on TV.
Dorinda on three martinis
isn't so good.
I'm great at two,
not so great at three.
-You're good TV at three,
though.
This one went uber-viral
during the pandemic.
Everyone just sent this around.
Someone said, "How you doing?"
You go, "I'll tell you
how I'm doing. Not well..."
-Bitch!
-Yeah. Yeah.
-And I said it
to Candace Bushnell.
That was the biggest joke of it.
But let me tell you
something about that.
I made a lot of money on mugs
off of that one
during the pandemic.
-Mugs? Oh, really?
-I mean, I could not
keep them in stock.
Mugs, totes, and sweatshirts.
I couldn't pack that [bleep]
fast enough.
Oh, you can't swear.
[ Laughter ]
-Mom! Hey, Mom, Dad, mute the --
mute the TV for a second.
-I couldn't pack that stuff
fast enough.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-When you do stuff like this,
did you know that
you wanted to be on TV
and wanted to be a housewife?
-No.
-You didn't? You didn't know?
-It was never
in my thought process.
I really thought that sort of
Hannah would go to college,
and Richard and I would live
happily ever after
in the Berkshires.
Kind of live in London
and New York
and do that sort of
"after kids are gone" thing.
But everything changed.
And then, you know, I got a call
if I was interested.
And I met with people.
And a month later, I was on.
You want to hear
a funny story, Jimmy?
-Of course.
-Here I go again.
I'll tell you something.
I remember I was filming
with Ramona Singer,
my first scene in the Hamptons.
-Love her.
-Yep.
And I'm going to
tell you something.
The camera came around
the corner, and I thought,
"Hm, I like the camera, and
I think the camera likes me."
-You felt it?!
-I felt it.
-You felt it right there.
-And from there on, I was like,
"This works for me."
-Yeah, you're a star.
-I don't know if I was a star,
but I liked the whole banter.
-You are fantastic,
and you're one of my favorites.
I'm so happy
that you're on the show.
-Thank you.
-You're so good.
I want to show a clip.
Here's Dorinda Medley
In "The Real Housewives
Ultimate Girls Trip:
Ex-Wives Club."
You can watch this one.
Take a look.
-There was food in the bedrooms.
I don't like food
in the bedrooms.
-You know what?
Marco brought us yogurts.
-Fruit, yogurt.
[ Indistinct conversations ]
-I just don't do food --
-I agree with you.
-'Cause you know what?
-You should know.
-I'm so petrified of mice
and things.
-I actually have that policy
at my house.
-It says it on the plaque.
"Clear liquid."
Everyone has a plaque
in their room.
-There's so much going on
in that room...
hanging off the ceiling.
-Let me get the plaque.
-Oh, no, I got it.
I don't need the plaque.
-I'll get the plaque.
-I don't need the plaque,
Dorinda. I got it.
No food in the room.
She's so worried
about rats and mice.
Why did she put cupcakes
in our room?
-Dorinda Medley, everybody.
Catch new episodes of
"The Real Housewives
Ultimate Girls Trip:
Ex-Wives Club,"
only on Peacock.